police in California are now
investigating multiple murders in the
city of Stockton as the work of a
possible serial killer they say the
crimes all happen within the last few
months in the same part of the city
there are no suspects but investigators
have released this image of a person
they are calling a person of interest
Dania Backus has the story
by definition you could probably very
well call this a
serial killings the police chief says
the five male victims were ambushed shot
while alone at night in dimly lit areas
the murders happened between July and
September and north Stockton the victims
were between the ages of 21 to 54 all
but one were Hispanic the fact that 80
percent
of the five homicide victims our
Hispanic is very concerning but
I want to appear on camera says her Zine
35 year old Paul yaw was the first
victim she says he was a good person
with a big heart at the time of his
death what did investigators tell you he
was talking
with him whatever and shot him multiple
times and now knowing you know that
person's out there doing this to
multiple people it's like it's just
horrible police tell CBS News there is
firearm evidence linking the murders
together they also released this picture
of a person of interest but aren't
ruling out others could be involved we
believe this may be a person of interest
that can provide information on maybe
one two three four five we just don't
know at this time for bogrow an arrest
can't come soon enough
for CBS morning's Don yubakis in Los
Angeles